in 10 days the must-see movie of the
year arrives spectacular I want to get a
closer look at this it'll break the rock
your world that's what heroes do
the revolution has begun the boldest
Morkel film yet I'm just a huge fan
Thor Ragnarok rated pg-13 November 3rd
so much has happened since I last saw
you I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
[Music]
Wow you have no idea how loved the
goddess of death is invaded as God oh I
miss this
and you and I had a flag race tonight
did I win now I want easily since I'm
right that's true
that's God is dead it'll be reborn in my
energy I thought you'd be Claire to see
me need a stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
[Music]
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools yeah same old like
fire door like water kind of like fire
but whole like raging fire so I like
smoldering fire
[Music]